welcome back everyone I'm James Murphy
Python 3.12 has just released here's
my take on all the latest and greatest
my company is mCoding we do software consulting
check us out at mcoding.io
fans of static typing will be pleased to
know about the biggest change in Python 3.12
the new syntax for type
parameters and the type statement
when defining a generic function in Python
you can now declare type variables
for the function in brackets
previously you had to import TypeVar
and create your own type variable
making sure the name that you assign
it to matches the name in quotes
that's no longer necessary just put brackets T
you could also put multiple
type variables like this
TypeVarTuples like this
and ParamSpecs like this
you could also constrain the
allowed types like this or like this
this syntax is even more convenient
for defining generic classes
previously defining generic
classes was very confusing
you have to import stuff and
define your own type variables
and then you have to learn about category
theory and pick the right type of
variance for your type variable
that used to be super annoying and confusing but
thanks to python 3.12 it's now no longer necessary
you don't even have to know
about covariance anymore
python just does the right thing
it automatically determines it
you can now also use the type keyword
to define your own type aliases
you could sort of already do this by declaring a
type alias like this but this usage is deprecated
and notice that this type alias is
defined before Expected is defined
that's fine these type
aliases are evaluated lazily
and they can even be generic too go wild
this new syntax is going to
make generics in Python a lot
less cumbersome to write so if you love
static typing I rate this 8 out of 10
if you hate static typing
I'll still rate it 3 out of 10
next up PEP 701 f-strings are now officially
formally part of the Python grammar
for historical reasons they used to
be implemented in a kind of hacky way
one of the consequences of that hack is that
you couldn't use the same kind of quotes that
started the f-string inside one of the
f-string expressions-- without escaping
python would see that quote and think you're
trying to end the f-string in an unbalanced way
well no more you can now put whatever expression
you want inside an f-string
including another f-string
but of course just because you can doesn't
mean you should-- keep things readable
all around this is a great update that gets
rid of an ugly wart that python had 9 out of 10
next up PEP 684 a unique per interpreter GIL
did you know you can have
multiple python interpreters
in the same process-- even in the same thread
here an interpreter means the part of python that
runs in a loop reading and
executing python bytecode
the main purpose of a sub
interpreter is to provide isolation
each sub interpreter is like a
little sandbox that can execute
code independently from the other interpreters
it has its own globals, imports, etc.
an example usage is something like mod_wsgi
for security reasons a web server serving multiple
different applications should keep
data for each application separate
therefore mod_wsgi creates a sub
interpreter for each application group
when a request comes in a worker will
acquire and use the sub interpreter
dedicated to that application group
so where does PEP 648 come in? well
python has this thing called the GIL
the global interpreter lock
but that also means python is limited
in multi-threaded performance because
only the thread that currently holds
the GIL can actually run python code
while sub interpreters do provide isolation
there's still a small amount of
state that's shared between them
and in particular the GIL is--
or WAS shared between them
this PEP makes it so each interpreter gets
its own GIL which will allow True
multi-threaded performance in Python
for the very small number of projects
that actually use sub interpreters
in summary a per interpreter GIL is a great idea
it just only applies to a
few projects so 6 out of 10
have you ever tried debugging your python
application and found it to be unbearably slow
compared to when you just run it normally
introducing pep 669 low impact monitoring
well here's a direct quote from the pep
by using quickening we expect that code run under
a debugger on 3.12 should outperform
code run without a debugger on 3.11
previously python debuggers worked using
sys.settrace which allows essentially
the same functionality in a less efficient way
the new sys.monitoring namespace provides
a clean API to register for events
and the implementation details allow
it to take advantage of the ongoing
work of specializing instructions at runtime
"quickening" as it was mentioned
before is the process of replacing
slow instructions with faster
specialized versions at runtime
this is all part of the faster
CPython project link below
anyway better debugging I'm
definitely in 8 out of 10
next up better error messages
particularly for common typos
did you forget a self dot somewhere
or use the wrong syntax for an import
now python will tell you
exactly what you did wrong
these are small changes but
literally every developer
benefits from better error messages 10 out of 10
ahh yes PEP 683 Immortal
objects-- this is a juicy one
do you run a Django app with over
2 billion monthly active users
if so this is the most exciting
python 3.12 update for you
you see if you have two billion users
you're going to need to fork a lot of
worker processes to handle all
those requests they generate
good thing forking is so fast on
Linux because it uses copy on write
but wouldn't it just be a darn shame if
every read in Python was also a write
oh wait every read in Python is
also a write because when you
read a python object first
you increase its ref count
that's a write
too bad that's going to trash
your cache and ruin your day
introducing Immortal objects
twiddle one of those high bits in an
object's ref count and poof it's now Immortal
Immortal objects do not participate
in ref counting because they're meant
to live forever-- at least
until interpreter shut down
there's no point in keeping track of
how many people have references to None,
True, False, and other global immutable built-ins
make them Immortal too
with Immortals now you can have
a read that's really just a read
2 out of 10 I don't have 2
billion monthly active users
next up PEP 709 comprehension inlining
previously dictionary list
and set comprehensions like
these were defined under the hood using functions
meaning it literally compiles the inside
of a comprehension as a separate function
which it then instantiates and calls immediately
that creates a bit of overhead
because you now have to create
this function object and create a
stack frame when you call the function
well that's no more they
change the implementation,
dictionary list and set comprehensions
no longer use functions under the hood
all the comprehensions get compiled
inline inside this function
hopefully you won't really notice this change
you'll get a slightly different traceback if
you have an exception inside a comprehension
because there's no longer this stack
frame associated with the comprehension
and since comprehensions are now
compiled inline you can now see
the local variables of the outer
function with a call to locals
as opposed to the local variables
of that inner lambda function scope
I mean it's a tiny Improvement
but why not 6 out of 10
next up PEP 688 using the
buffer protocol from python
the buffer protocol is a common interface
allowing many libraries like numpy to
interoperate as long as they can
conceptualize their data storage
as some kind of n-dimensional array determined
by a few properties like the number of
dimensions shape strides and element size
previously the buffer interface
was only accessible in the C API
this pep exposes that interface
to python by adding two new magic
dunder methods __buffer__ and __release_buffer__
the usefulness of buffers in Python
is limited but it could be useful
for debugging or potentially building a
bridge type that connects two C extensions
I probably won't use it 4 out of 10
next up PEP 692 using TypedDict to annotate kwargs
the default way that you annotate keyword
arguments in Python is not very intuitive
kwargs is always going to be
a dictionary and the keys of
the the dictionary are always going to be strings
so originally python decided that that means
you just need to annotate the value type
so if I annotate kwargs as an int this means
that it's a dictionary of string to int
that's already confusing enough
but also when would I want just
an arbitrary number of extra keyword
arguments that all have to be integers?
if you have a use case I'd love to
hear your thoughts comment below
if I was going to take a bunch of keyword
arguments I'd probably want them
to have some specific structure
a typed dictionary seems like a
perfect match for defining the
structure of a dictionary so why don't we use that
we can't just type hint kwargs
as a movie because remember
that's going to be interpreted as
a dictionary of strings to movies
well in 3.12 they added Unpack
into the typing library which
instructs the type checker to do
what you would hope it would do
namely treat kwargs like it's supposed
to be one of these typed dictionaries
I'll give it 4 out of 10 I guess I would
really prefer to do this instead of using
kwargs but kwargs are part of the language so
we should at least be able to type them properly
next up developers who are paid by the
line of code are going to love this one
PEP 698 the typing override decorator
let's say you have a class hierarchy
we have a base class shape
that has a calc_area method
then we have squares and
triangles that are both shapes
both Square and Triangle have their own
specialized way of calculating their area
the programmer then uses the override
decorator to signal that yes this
implementation of calc_area is meant to be
an override of something in a base class
this doesn't really do much at runtime but
when we run our type checker we find a problem
the method used to be called get_area but we
did a big refactor and it's now called calc_area
but it looks like we missed a spot and
there's still a get_area floating around
the base class may have even
had a correct albeit slower
implementation of calc_area for the triangle
so potentially all of our tests still pass
but because this method is marked override
and there's no get_area function left in the
parent class this now becomes a type error
that we can catch at static analysis time
there's also a suggested strict mode
that would make it a type error if you
didn't mark the function as override when
it was overriding something in a base class
this could potentially stop you from
accidentally overriding something
in a base class that you didn't
know existed in the first place
my only fear is this might be the second
step along the way to becoming C++ with their
"public static constexpr auto const override"
that you need to slap on every definition
hopefully it won't come to that 5 out of 10
next up PEP 689 introducing
the Unstable C API tier
lots about the C API in this release, huh?
this pep introduces the unstable API which has the
same compatibility requirements as the public API
but does not require deprecation
warnings before change
so this contains things that are basically
expected to change with every version of python
this would be useful for something like a debugger
that might use specific op codes that are
only valid in specific versions of python
currently everything the unstable
tier is related to code objects
so unless you're using the C API this probably
won't affect you but good to be aware 6 out of 10
and the most painful change not
even a pep for this one setuptools
is no longer included by default in a virtualenv
this change is undoubtedly going
to break some people's builds
setuptools has been the default and
de-facto standard for building and
packaging your python code for a long time now
and many people generally expect it to be there
with that said setuptools is no
longer the only build system for
Python and it doesn't make sense to pre-install it
pip still works even if setuptools is
not installed but it's still painful
to break someone's build so
I'll give it a 1 out of 10
but ultimately I do agree with the pip
team that this needed to be done eventually
there's also a ton of tiny improvements to many
libraries but I'm not going through all those
let me just mention my favorite
gem-- itertools.batched,
10 out of 10 I write batched over and over again
it's in like 80% of my codebases glad to
see it included in the standard library
all it does is split an iterable into
batches of a fixed size in this case 3
so I get 1 2 3, 4 5 6, except
the last one might be shorter
and finally saving the best for last the absolute
most awesome part of python 3.12 being released
is that python 3.7 is now past its end of life and
I can drop support for it in all of my code bases
and python 3.8 has a year to go so I can
start pushing clients to upgrade to 3.9
again I'm James Murphy don't forget to check
out my consulting services at mcoding.io
thanks to my patrons and donors
see you in the next one